Qué efectos prácticos tiene el número de
sillas alcanzado por la ultraderecha por
ejemplo si hay una Unión con la derecha
tradicional
bueno bien interesante tu pregunta
porque lo que estamos viviendo en Chile
es un poco esquizofrénico probablemente
si se mira desde afuera por qué porque
hace dos años y me votó principalmente
mayoritariamente hacia la izquierda
dándole una entrega total de los votos a
los partidos tanto de la centro
izquierda como de la izquierda chilena
dos años después la realidad es
totalmente distinta al cuatro de
septiembre lo pudimos ver con el rechazo
al proyecto constitucional y hoy día el
cuatro de septiembre se vuelve a repetir
chile una enorme cantidad de votos más
de tres millones y medio de votos de un
Universo de 12 millones de votantes se
fueron y se inclinaron hacia esta
extrema hacia una derecha conservadora
que es la que representa el líder
conservador de ultraderecha José Antonio
kast la pregunta que tú hacías Valentina
justamente es clave se va a alinear esta
y del Consejo constitucional que parte
el próximo seis de junio con la derecha
tradicional es una de las grandes dudas
porque eventualmente podría existir una
posibilidad de que la derecha
tradicional pudiera pactar con algunos
sectores de la centro izquierda que son
pocos pero que podrían pactar y hacer un
solo bloque eso es lo que está en juego
a contar de las próximas semanas bueno
volviendo al resultado Qué significa
dentro de la sociedad chilena
significa que hay un descontento que hay
también un voto muy transaccional esto
quiere decir que si bien muchos de los
votantes de José Antonio kast de los
republicanos como se llaman en Chile
este colectivo dice ok podemos debatir
sobre temas constitucionales Pero lo que
más me interesa es poder cambiar mi auto
tener acceso evidentemente a cambiar
teléfono en fin todo lo que tiene que
ver mucho de ellos va de la mano con el
consumo más que un tema de identidad
ideológica y por eso y es la única forma
que habría para poder entenderlo muchos
de ellos no tienen problemas luego de
cruzar a votar con la izquierda ante una
posibilidad de que se pudiera asegurar
algo de lo que ya estaba
individualizando de alguna manera este
resultado puede ser una forma de
castigar al gobierno
sí efectivamente cuando se habla de una
votación transaccional En mi opinión es
una forma de castigar al gobierno y en
su minuto lo hicieron también con
Sebastián Piñera y se castigó a la
derecha o a la centro derecha que
gobernaba en su oportunidad votando
masivamente por el líder izquierdista
Gabriel borich que en ese minuto en
primera vuelta había tenido un mal
desempeño electoral sin embargo en la
segunda vuelta presidencial de chile
logró tener un aumento importantísimo en
cuanto a los votos es decir votos
transaccionales donde podrían
evidentemente no son ideológicos y
podrían cruzar de un lado a otro sin
ningún problema
Bueno y qué se espera de la ultraderecha
y de la derecha tradicional en la
redacción de la nueva constitución
es un tema bien importante porque hasta
ahora para resumirlo existe una comisión
experta que son veinticuatro personas
designadas dos y doce por los sectores
políticos con representación
parlamentaria es un goteo casi perfecto
entre los partidos tradicionales dentro
de esos veinticuatro expertos solo el
partido republicano tiene a uno y el
partido comunista que es otro partido
que le fue bastante bien el día de ayer
tiene uno solo esto quiere decir que
durante el proceso propiamente tal de
instalación del Consejo constitucional
del seis de junio en adelante hay que
ver si se va a respetar las reglas y los
márgenes y bordes que se entregaron por
parte de esta comisión experta o esto
definitivamente podría terminar siendo
un momento muy tenso de un debate
constitucional que se podría extender
incluso al borde del próximo plebiscito
que sería el de salida en el mes de
diciembre por eso es que todavía no hay
Claridad sobre si republicanos va a
pactar o no con los escaños de la
derecha tradicional y hacer un solo
proyecto donde puedan ensamblarse o
definitivamente Esto va a ser una
atención permanente